ces paquets la contiennent des semences
traitées à l'insecticide régent
aujourd'hui elles sont encore
conditionné chez limagrain l'un des
leaders européens même si la production
a été arrêtée ce fabricant cherche à
écouler ses stocks
bien entendu nous avons été tous
fabrication selon stema hills et de
tournesol fait que revient cette année
jean claude labit céréaliers à commander
150 kg de semences traitées aux régions
pour les semis de printemps il n'a pas
d'autre choix que de les utiliser et ils
se justifient agriculteurs utilisent ce
produit parce qu'à ce jour pour eux
c'est la meilleure solution en terme de
travail en termes d'efficacité en termes
de gestion technico économique
si le produit nocif les agriculteurs si
on leur donne la preuve que le produit
nocif
les agriculteurs arrêterons d'utiliser
ce produit là annoncé trop tardivement
cette mesure de suspension ne pourra
concrètement s'appliquer qu'à partir de
2005 cet été les abeilles continueront
vraisemblablement de mourir par milliers
au grand dam des apiculteurs et de
philippe de villiers qui s'est portée
partie civile à leurs côtés parce que
les études scientifiques l'ont montré
qu'il ya un risque non seulement pour la
santé animale mais aussi pour la santé
humaine
il ya plus de questions économiques
quand on se souvient de ce qui s'est
passé pour l'amiante pour la vache folle
pour le sang contaminé
il ya un seul la seule question c'est
principe de précaution un principe de
précaution qui ne s'applique pas car il
n'existerait pas de solution alternative
à l'emploi des pesticides
on ne pourrait pas cultiver autant et
aussi bien sans insecticide adaptés à
chaque culture
pourtant les agriculteurs bio s'étonne
de ce discours et propose d'autres
méthodes
une terre qui a reçu pendant 20 ans du
maïs maïs sur maïs tous les ans balou
taupin il est comme un roi là donc c'est
tout à fait possible de s'en passer en
pratiquant des rotations c'est à dire
faire des successions de culture qui
n'ont pas les mêmes ravageur en
employant uniquement des méthodes
traditionnelles
andré de solon affirme avoir un
rendement inférieur d'un quart seulement
à celui d'un céréalier qui emploient des
pesticides
pour lui c'est le prix à payer pour
sauvegarder la santé des hommes et des
animaux